Hello, how are you? This is Next Level
Commander. I am Jin and today we are
looking at the last pre-constructed deck
from Final Fantasy. We're looking
through the cards and we are going to
cut some cards, figure out what this
deck does, and make some replacements to
try to bring this deck up to bracket
three. Uh, let's begin.
Okay, let's take a look here. To begin
with, this commander Cloud is really
powerful. It's ridiculous.
Yeah, it's so pushed as a equipment
commander. Just does everything. It's
got haste, so you can't really shut the
deck down unless you wipe all the
equipments and also it draws cards and
creates treasures. Yeah, it just does
everything as long as you keep him
protected and equipped and he even
equips himself. So, yeah, you just can't
lose. All right, starting off with
Cloud. This should be an equipment
stack.
And then Tifa. This card I know about,
the only reason I sounded a bit unsure
saying this is an equipment stacks is
because I know about Tifa. Tifa cares
about power seven or greater. And of
course, there's synergy between the two,
right? We can pump the creatures with
equipments. Yeah, so far it looks like
we're going equipments big power kind of
strategy. All right, cloud and tifa
sid free flyer pilot equipment and
vehicle spells you cast cost one less to
cast during your turn has flying. It's a
pilot return target equipment or vehicle
from your graveyard to your hand. Yeah,
we're off to a good start. This is an
excellent card. Cloud's limit break. Oh,
this one I've seen right in another deck
maybe. I don't remember, but it's a
decent removal. Destroy target type
creature, destroy any number of attack
creatures, and destroy all attack
creatures. Yeah, it's like uh yeah, it's
nice at least when your opponents are
are attacking you, you can use this to
to kill all the attackers, right? So,
and also sometimes you can just use the
two mana or the three mana for some
decent flexible removal options. So,
it's good.
All right, Elena. When Elena enters,
return target non-assinant historic card
from your graveyard to your hand. Yeah,
it's very open-ended. You can return
artifacts. You can return legendary
creatures. Whenever you cast a historic
spell, you put a counter on Elena. It's
not the strongest ability, but she can
get big and uh three mana to return
something relevant to this deck. It's
decent. Yeah.
High dagger Shinra executive. At the
beginning of combat on your turn, target
creature you control gets plus X plus O
X number of soldiers you control. At the
beginning of your end stop, create a
number of one- one white soldier tokens.
Is this good?
I mean, Shinra can pump your creatures,
which is nice. Sorry, I mean, High
Digger. And at the same time, we are not
a deck that goes wide. So, the token
creation ability is useful for just
holding the ground while we beat people
with cloud.
Yeah. So I think by himself you drop
him, he will easily create three or four
creatures and the next turn give
something plus three plus old pump. So
that's a decent synergy I'd say.
Yeah, this deck is starting well. Maybe
it's because the my expectations are low
after seeing some of the other decks.
But yeah, this is nice. Hella trooper
two mana flying whenever this creature
attacks another target attacking
creature of King's flying equip
abilities cost two less uh equipilities
targeting this creature.
So, it's like a decent.
It helps give it give evasion to our
commander and if our commander gets
killed, it's an okay backup equipment
carrier.
This deck, this card is not the
strongest.
Yeah, I'm tempted to cut or to maybe
this for now just because we don't want
to equip onto this. We want to equip
onto our commander. If it said equip
abilities always cost two less uh for
any target, then it's excellent. But for
asis, I'll keep it in the maybe pile.
Soldier military program. Three mana.
The beginning of combat. If you control
your commander, create a one- one
soldier. And put a co counter on each of
up to two soldiers I control. How many
soldiers do we have? We have our
commander is a soldier. High dagger
makes soldiers. Hide digger is a
soldier. Anyone else? Let's see. How
about Tifa? Tifa is a monk.
So,
let's see. We are creating a soldier
token and
pumping it and our commander by one.
I don't think this does enough.
Yeah, I want this deck to be more
focused on just equipments and big
creatures and this does neither. Like
it's kind of nice to make tokens, but
like compared to hide, hide makes
probably at least two or three a turn
and it pumps better as a more relevant
pump to our game plan. Meanwhile, this
is uh does a bit bit of everything but
doesn't do enough. So, well, maybe this
ultimate magic. Holy permanence you
control get indestructible. If this
spell was cast from exile, so if you
forell it, it's got for you forell and
then so you pay two and then three, you
get to protect your board and
your life total. Yeah, I think this is a
really good protection spell. It's no
fair protection, but it's it's very good
at what what it does. Yeah, for three
mana is super reasonable. You don't
always have to fortell it. Great card.
Avalanche of sector 7. Three mana x3
manace. This powers equals the number of
artifacts my opponent's controls. This
is pretty big.
Whenever an opponent activates an
ability of an artifact they control,
avalanche deals one damage to that
player. Uh, this card is not super
impactful, but it's easily like a 10,
right, with all the treasure and soul
rings running around. So, it's very
aggressive and it's dealing damage to
Yeah. against the treasure decks,
against easily your opponents are taking
two damage a turn, right? At least just
because of how commander is, how reli
how reliant people are on artifacts. So,
I think this is fine. Our deck looks
fairly aggressive. Yeah, this might get
cut later. It's like a slightly above
neutral, I'd say, for for what we want
to do. Kate Sith,
at the beginning of combat, scry one and
then exile the top uh see the top card
of your library. I may play it. When you
exile that card, target creature gets
plus X plus O or access the card's mana
value.
It's okay. Card advantage
scribe scribe one and then exile. So you
can choose to, for example, if you need
a land, you can choose to play the land
or you can choose to keep something or
try to find something big on top to pump
your creature. Is that good enough?
Possibly. Yeah, this one is difficult.
This one is difficult cuz it is card
advantage in Nia cuz Nia isn't I mean
green is good at drawing cards, but only
a few cards only a few cards do that. So
I think we'll keep it in for now because
it does what we want to do.
Summon Kuata.
It's a seven five trample haste. This
deals damage to target two target
creatures for six mana. And then you can
give evasion to your board and discard a
card then draw two. When you discard
this way, this creature deals damage
equal to that card's mana value to each
opponent.
Um I'm a little bit worried just because
our commander is equipments
and we are putting so many I mean so far
we haven't seen anything that cares
about equipments except for that one
card. Sid, what's his name? Yeah, all
the other cards are beat down aggro, big
power.
So later, if we don't see enough
equipments, we might have to cut some of
these to make room for equipments just
because again, the payoff for equipments
is ridiculous with our commander.
There's no reason to not go full
equipments.
But if I cut all these non-equipment,
the cards that don't care about
equipments, I don't think I feel like
we'll have another just to where we cut
so many cards. So, we'll try to keep it
for now and later. I suspect in the
second segment of this video, there
might be some major changes just after
seeing the whole deck. So, again, it's a
good card. It's a very aggressive, a
great card. So, we'll keep it for now.
Ultimate Magic Meteor.
right here. Seven damage to each
creature. Sorcery. It's a board wipe,
but if it was cast from exile, you can
destroy an artifact or land for each
opponent.
It's decent. I mean, to to foretell it
is a bit expensive, but just doing it
for six mana,
I get it. I think they're trying to be a
little bit more make it asymmetrical
where your creatures are bigger and but
seven damage really doesn't kill
everything, but I think it's
serviceable. And the option to kill
artifacts and lands is nice because if
some opponent has for example a maze of
we have to deal with that. So yeah it's
good utility.
Next up Vincente Vengefuler
three mana menace. Whenever one or more
creatures you control deal combat damage
to a player put a plus one counter on
it. Whenever a Vincent deals combat
damage to an opponent it deals that much
damage to each other opponent if his
power is seven.
whenever one or more creatures deals
combat damage to a player. So, you have
to go wide. You have to be attacking
multiple opponents for Vincent to get
uh
I'm not sure how the ordering works
actually. So, if you're attacking this
turn, say Vincent is four power and then
you attack with each uh you're attacking
each opponent and you get through. Does
this trigger because Vincent first grows
to seven power?
Uh, I think it still triggers. I think
it still triggers. Not super not not
make or break, but because we have other
ways to pump instant, but yeah, looks
like we are a seven power deck with a
equipment sub theme.
Yuthi materia hunter njutsu. When Yuthi
enters can control target nontrol
artifact for as long as you control
Yuthi, you may attach an equipment you
control to Yuthi.
So you can steal something,
but what are we returning to the hand?
Like this doesn't have it seems like
it's got equipment synergy, but not
much. And at the same time, it doesn't
have Inju doesn't really work with the
rest of our deck. I guess we can just
cast it for free. We don't really need
to return it or return another creature,
but I think it's Yeah, it's not as
impactful as I'd like our cards to be.
It doesn't doesn't do enough, I feel. So
maybe Bugenhagen the wise elder two mana
reach at the beginning of your upkeep.
If you control a creature with power
seven or greater draw a card it's upkeep
in two mana add one mana of any color.
It's not bad. It's not great. Uh mana
manadors are nice I guess.
Okay fine fine fine. Where are our
equipments? Live streams blessing.
Draw X cards will access the greatest
power among creatures you control.
Instant. Okay, this is solid. And if we
cast with Forell, we gain twice X life.
This is really good. Yeah, very powerful
card. There are a few green cards with
this effect, but this is one of the
best, I think. And worth noting is that
this counts greatest power of creatures
I control as I cast this spell. This is
a huge difference because your opponents
can't just remove your creature in
response to to nullify this. Excellent.
Professor Hojo two mana. The first
activated ability activate during your
turn targets a creature uh cost two less
to activate. So one equip is close to
free, I guess. Whenever one or more
creatures you control becomes target of
an active ability, draw a card. Yeah,
this seems good. You're in this deck
again. Hopefully we have equipments. We
are guaranteed a card a turn.
Yeah, seems good.
So, this deck is half equipments, half
large creatures, which is acceptable, I
guess. But I I think again with how
amazing how amazingly broken Cloud is,
it's better off. We're better off just
doing equipments.
Yeah. So, that's kind of a direction we
can go later. But for now, we have to
kind of keep the balance a little bit.
Okay. Summoning materia. Three mana. You
may look at the top card. Oh, it's an
equipment. Nice. As long as this
equipment is attached to a creature, you
may cast creature spells from the top
top from my library. Equip creature gets
plus two plus two has vigilance and add
mana.
Cost five mana to equip
this. Uh, but once you equip, you get
refunded one mana. I don't think this
does enough. I have like off the top of
my head, I can think of probably 20
better equipments than this. And plus
two doesn't even get us to seven power.
Yeah. So, I don't think this is good
enough. It will be cool in other decks.
I don't know, maybe but not in here. I
last ancient.
Four mana life link at the beginning of
the end step. If you gain life this
turn, return target creature from your
graveyard to your hand. If I gain seven
more life, seven or more life, return
that card to the battlefield. And she's
got lifelink and three power. We don't
gain life in this deck aside from Aith.
So, I guess the point is to pump Eric in
uh to seven power attack and then return
something.
Yeah, a lot of things have to fall in
place. So, let's see how much pump we
have right so far. Right. We don't have
that much pump.
Yeah. One,
two,
three, I guess. Yeah. I don't think this
is again a I know is a very important
character in the game. So they have to
top down her. They can't just make her
care about equipments for make her, you
know, force her into a seven power
theme. They So they kind of danced
around it. But the result is that we are
not Yeah, there isn't enough synergy for
ath to work well in this deck. But I
know she's a key character, so if you
like her, she's fine. It's a great card.
But for now, we'll cut her. We'll put
her in the maybe pile. Next up, Barrett,
Avalanche Leader. Whenever an equipment
you control enters, create a two two red
rebel creature token. At the beginning
of combat on your turn, attach up to one
target equipment to target rebel. Who's
a rebel? Oh, he's a rebel. Eh,
can't attach to our commander. But
if we have, let's say, at least 15
equipments in this deck, I think it's
fine. And even if there isn't, I'm
pretty sure I'm going to modify this
deck to put in more equipments just
because that is the most again the most
powerful way to do to make this. So, he
will stay in for now.
Red, what is this? 13. Proud warrior
vigilance trample three mana. Other
modified creatures you control have
vigilance and trample. See, this is how
you what's it called? How you batch it,
right? Modified cuz we're doing plus one
counters. We're doing equipments. Why
don't we have more of this wording in in
this deck? I don't understand. When red
three uh 13 enters, return target or or
equipment from your graveyard to your
hand. Again, if we have enough
equipments, this is excellent. Great
card. Sepharoth. Holy,
isn't he black? So, they made a red
white version of him.
It's cool.
Five mana 75. Whenever Sephro attacks,
what you may put a cell counter on each
on target creature until the end of turn
and then each modified creature gets is
a 75. Yeah, this is really forcing our
theme here. And it's so aggressive. It's
pretty good.
Yeah, he doesn't have to attack because
the moment he enters, our commander
becomes seven power just because he's
most likely equipped. And also, you can
sacrifice a modified creature, return
this card from your graveyard to the
battlefield. So, if you put this cell
counter onto something smaller and
later, you can use that to recur
Sephoroth. So, this is just again, I
think they did well on this design in
that it probably fits the cards flavor,
but at the same time, it works really
well in this deck. Unfortunately, it
seems like this kind of design is
difficult to do, but at least they used
it on the most important character,
right? So, we can keep it in.
Oo, artifacts. Exciting. Conformer
shuriken. Two mana equipped creature
has. Whenever this creature attacks, tap
target creature. And if that creature
has greater power than this creature,
you make up for the difference in plus
one counters.
H.
So you can move this onto different
creatures every turn just to pump it. Is
that worth it? Like when you drop clouds
on say turn five,
you put this onto cloud for free and
then
what's the chance of your opponent
having say a seven seven for us to for
us to grow off of?
I think it's it's reasonable. Okay, I'll
play with this to see but on paper it's
okay.
And again, my my sander has been
lowered.
Yeah. So, we'll keep it for now.
Wrecking ball arm two mana. The creature
has base power and toughness 7 seven.
Yeah, it can be blocked by small
creatures and you can equip for three.
And most of our creatures are legendary
creatures. So, yeah, seems good. Auster
command reprints. Great card. That's it
for new cards.
I hope they reprinted some good
equipments. Honestly, I hope because so
far the equipments have been not good,
have been subpar. Okay, Oscar command,
great card. Bastion Protector pumps our
commander by two, not three, but gives
it indestructible.
I'd rather do this with an equipment.
Um, but
right now, how many cards are we cutting
potentially? Let's see. We're cutting
just five cards.
We'll see. But I'd rather have this
effect on an equipment. I know it's a
powerful card, but plus two doesn't
quite get us there, right? We need one
more pump to trigger most of our
creatures, including our commander.
Well, actually only our commander just
because this guy only cares about our
commander and cloud requires seven
power. So, we'll put this in the maybe
pile
bronze guardian double strike.
W two other artifacts have double word
two. This creature's power is equal to
the number of artifacts I control. No, I
don't control that many artifacts. He's
a one five to begin with and then I'm
guessing at the average game, the
average board will have three to four
artifacts. I don't think this is good
enough. Like it's a cool aggressive
creature, but we don't really need ward
on our artifacts. If it was like our
commander has ward maybe. Yeah. Again,
this is a great card, but I can think of
better cards in this deck for this deck.
I mean, clever concealment. this this
art. I'll just hold for a few seconds
for you to for you to admire this art.
Yeah, you notice one of them is
different.
Yeah, it's her cuz she's shown her
shoulders.
Anyways, this is one of the best
protection spells. Play it. Pure Steel
Paladin. There you go. There you go.
This is the kind of reprint you put into
uh precon decks.
Unfinished business. Five mana. return
target creature card from your graveyard
to the battlefield. Then return up to
two aura or equipment cards from your
graveyard attached to that creature.
Seems good.
Again,
we'll have to have at least 15
equipments in this deck. If we don't, I
am Yeah, I'm adding them cuz this card
these cards don't work unless we have
we can reach the threshold. Vanquish the
horde. Excellent board wipe.
Not much to say. Usually it will cost
two mana, so you will be the first to
rebuild. Imagine wiping the board and
then recasting cloud to smack someone.
That's the kind of play you want to do.
Chaos W premium removal. Although in
white arguably you have better options
also. Also green, but it's fine. It's
still good. Hite Tyrant. That's a cool
reprint. But this card does not work in
our deck. I know you care about
equipments kind of, but not really.
So, no
professional face breaker. Whenever one
or more creatures you control deals
damage to a player
again, it's an excellent card. Excellent
card. But where's the synergy? Oh, I
guess. H. Okay, there's treasure
synergy.
You know what? That is good enough just
because this card by itself is already a
really powerful card and we have some
synergy with treasures and even without
our commander, we can easily beat our
opponents and create what? Three
treasures a turn. Should two to three?
Not too difficult. And then we can turn
that into card advantage. Something we
need. Decimate. This is not a good
removal just because one is a sorcery.
And two, you need an artifact, a
creature, an enchantment, and a land.
You need those targets. And often times
there's no enchantment on the field
often times. And this just this is a
dead card in your hand. So we will uh
replace this with another another
removal. Armory automaton. Whenever this
creature enters or attacks, you may he
can pick up all the equipments. It can
pick up all the equipments. It's like a
decent backup for our commander.
I think it's fine. Would have been nice
if it had haste, but
yeah, it's okay. It's okay. We'll keep
it for now. Champions Helm. Excellent
equipment. Protects our commander and
plus two is not quite enough, but still
pretty good. Equip is cheap. Yeah, just
a really good equipment. Conqueror's
flail. Wow. Equipped
creature gets plus one plus one for each
color upon permanence control. Um, as
long as it's attached, your opponents
can't cast spells during your turn.
Yeah, that's a really powerful effect
just because if your opponent has
removal, they're not sure who you're
attacking. Maybe they'll fire it off
when you attack them. The moment you
equip this, they lose that opportunity.
And you can play some like for example
you can play some palm spells after you
can turn a notlethal looking board state
into something lethal but they can no
longer respond. And this gives plus
three to our commander. What a perfect
equipment. Dark steel plate. Yeah, even
though again this is kind of power crept
by the myth cult but it's still a good
card I think.
Yeah, it's just great value. So I play
it personally. Inspiring statuary. This
is like a mana rock, but it allows all
of our equipments to tap to help cast
our creatures and our commander.
Yeah, this is a good mana rock. Sword of
the animist. Great equipment. That's
sweet art, too. Yeah, we'll play it.
Let's skip the lens for now.
Okay, here you go,
Zach.
Focus.
There you go. Zach fair one mana
interest with a counter. Sacrifice it.
Target creature ganks indestructible and
then put the counters and equipment on
Zach onto that creature.
Yeah, I don't think this is impactful
enough. I'd rather just play a
protection spell. Like we're not putting
equipments onto Zach, right? So, let's
not get ourselves. So, we're just
transferring a plus one counter. Yeah, I
I'd rather have a protection spell than
this
Barrett Wallace. Oh, these are new cards
again. What's with the way they sort
these decks, man? Also, what's with me
noticing this on the fourth deck?
I am slow.
Okay,
Barrett Wallace. Whenever Barrett
attacks, it deals damage equal to the
number of equipped creatures you control
to defend to the defend defending
player. So normally this is what two
damage three damage max to one player.
This is not impactful enough.
Even if this was to each opponent, I
wouldn't play it. So yeah, this card is
just weak. Dispatch, no. There are
better removals. We don't want to play
conditional removals.
Secret rendevous. You and target
opponent each draw three cards.
We are pretty desperate for card draw.
So I'd say this is okay. You can help
someone,
right? Or you let them draw three cards
and you kill them.
So, this is fine. Gen Nia,
there are I mean, we are a big big
creature deck, so there are better draw
spells that care about creatures power
and toughness. So, I don't want to play
this. Okay, I don't want to play this
cuz we we have more synergistic ways to
draw cards to refill our hand. And this
is not it.
Furious Rice at the beginning of your
end step. If you control a creature with
power four greater, exile the top card.
You may play that card until you exile
another card. It's not good. We can just
play uh that green green enchantment
that draws cards whenever you have a
large creature. And this is Yeah, this
is far weaker. I think it's called Garuk
something. I'll put it on the screen,
but compare just compare the two, right?
It's not close.
Vendal blast sure is an excellent
removal. Cultivate. Good. Ramp spell
harmonize.
It's okay. It's okay. Nature slower.
Ramp is fine. Ramp. Yeah. Ramp. Ramp.
Equipment. Trample. Lifelink. Plus two.
Lifelink is good. We do need lifelink.
Yeah, not the best equipment, but it's
passable. Arcing signate. Cool. Colossus
hammer. This is like the payoff card for
our clouds free equipility.
So, we definitely play it. It's
hilarious. It doesn't do anything when
you don't have cloud, but
it's cool. If scope, whenever it
attacks, look at the top card of his
land, you put it into play. This is so
low impact. We are not going to play
this. Heroes play is good because you
can always play this first and then
yeah, it automatically equips the cloud
and then you can equip another equipment
and it's seven power, right? Plus three
plus two. So, this one has good synergy.
Heroes heirloom plus two plus one is
gets trample and haste but cloud already
has haste so it just gets trample and
plus two isn't enough so again this is a
really low impact carding grease sure
protection and also because we get to
move it around yeah so it's we have
multiple creatures this isn't going to
stop us from equipping so it's fine mask
of memory whenever equip creature deals
damage to a player you may draw two
cards
Yeah. Are we desperate for card draw?
I guess we're pretty desperate. Are
there no better draw spells?
It's fine. We'll keep it for now.
Uh the draw two discard one is nice.
Skull Clamp. Not the not at its best in
this deck, but still probably one of the
better equipments.
It's fine. Soul ring. Eh, it's okay.
Trailblazers blazers boots. Like, it
sounds fancy, but all this is is
unblockable. We have way better cards
than this. And now we're on to the
lands. Once again, the lands should be
literally the same with no synergy
whatsoever.
Basic, basic, basic.
Okay, this one is new. Bonders Enclave.
It's nice. It's decent.
Um,
scavenger ground. Oh, yeah. This one is
different. This is a great land. Slayer
stronghold. Haste, vigilance, plus two
plus. Spire of Industry.
Why do we need this? I mean, it's not
it's never terrible, but
okay. It's fine. It's fine. Yeah, we're
going to leave the land base untouched,
but everything else we will see. And
here are the tokens. Soldier.
Bunch of soldiers. Oh, Forell. That's
cool. That's nice. What's on the back?
Rebel and soldiers. Forell.
Sweet. Let's see how many cards are in
our maybe pile here. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17. More than I
thought. And we're going to open this
pack and move on to upgrading our deck.
Let's see what we get.
Premise and Mog Mughal Warrior. Awesome.
See you soon. Okay, now we have the
pile. So, we cut we end up cutting 17
cards, mostly ones that are not
impactful enough or just uh don't have
much synergy with the deck as usual. So,
for the deck itself, we have 37 Lens.
Once again, we don't touch these. Yeah,
they're fine. And
in terms of the core of the deck, it
looks like we've got two decks. We have
the Cloud deck, which is equipment
focused, and the Tifa deck, which is
seven power, the seven power theme.
There is some synergy, but they don't
mix too well with each other. And I've
decided to focus on the cloud theme with
the cards. I'm adding equipments. Yeah,
equipment synergy just because, you
know, Cloud is our commander, so that
makes a huge difference. But the Tifa
Tifa pile can also work in here. It's
not it's not terrible.
I ideally I will slowly slowly face out
this pile, but it's I I think the deck
will function just fine. So, uh outside
of this, we have draw spells, just two
of these. But to be fair, cloud does
draw cards. So, we are okay here. and
ramp spells. We got one, two, three,
four, five, six ramp spells. Yes,
six is okay. Once again, cloud does
everything. Cloud is draw cloud also
reps. So, you can you will see that I
put in a lot of protection spells just
to make sure that cloud happens because
as long as cloud happens, everything is
turned on. Okay, next up, some Yeah,
here are some protection spells, two of
them. I added a lot more. And here are
some removals and board wipes. So, we've
got here are the board wipes. Oh, some
glare. Yeah, for wipes and some and
three removals. It's not quite enough. I
added I think one or two because again I
want to focus on what this deck wants to
do, which is to smack people. It's like
if they're doing broken stuff, just try
to kill them. Yeah. So, this is kind of
interesting. So, I I I didn't go too
deep onto removals. All right. So, let's
take a look at the cards added. First of
all, our equipments and equipment
synergies. The first one is actually a
meta rock, but this is a sweet meta rock
for any equipment deck. It's a two drop
meta rock, which is already quite good,
but it also turns into an equipment that
gives conveniently plus three. So, what
happens is actually you can just drop
cloud. This will turn into an equipment
and I believe it can just equip and you
can immediately smack for smack for uh
seven, right? You can even tap this to
cast cloud and then equipment on the
cloud. you will have a tapped equipment,
but it doesn't matter. So, this is a a
sweet card. I think a lot of people miss
this card. Okay, next up, a Myith my
coat. Yeah, just a three mana. It's like
a pro protection spell kind of, but
three mana straight up indestructible is
too much value to pass up on. The next
one, locks on Warhammer. We need the
plus three. We need the trample and
lifelink is also important because our
deck is kind of, you know, we are
voltrony. We have usually one or two
creatures doing and stuff and we need
ways to kind of raise people to defend
ourselves and if we can't we need to
link we need to gain life. So lock down
Warhammer is sweet. Cauldra complete.
This one is to take advantage of Cloud's
free equip. Yeah. Equip seven doesn't
matter. We drop Cloud and this is
already on. And another reason is
because Cloud doesn't just care about
himself. He cares about all equipped
creatures. So living weapon is really
powerful here because you can just drop
Kra smack people and you will get the
you will get the draw out of the draw
you will get the yeah the draw trigger
extra draw trigger which is sweet.
Uh next up black blade reforged. I think
it's the most efficient power pump
equipment. Yeah, two mana and then three
to equip. You can get easily plus seven
in the mid game, maybe more. Yeah, this
is how you finish people sometimes.
And the swords are a lot of them are
really good, but they are quite
expensive. So, I just picked the best
one. Sword defeats the famine. Getting
your lens untapped is just it's just
amazing. Yeah, cuz usually on the turn
you're paying three and then two to
equip an equipment. That's like half
your turn or maybe all your turn gone.
But once you connect,
you can have another go at casting
spells, right? So, you don't you don't
you get both. You get the equipment and
you get to play things, play other
things. And also this protection is
decent and it's relevant for evasion.
You can get through to some players with
this sword. So, it's nice. And lizard
blades. This is one of the best cards
you can play in an equipment deck. Not
be not just because it gives double
strike. is probably the most efficient
double strike provider, but also is a
creature with double strike, which is
excellent for carrying equipments as a
backup. Yeah. So, wizard blades, it's
excellent. Ember cleave,
double strike, evasion, and you can
really surprise people with the flash
ability. Yeah. And uh auto equip, right?
So, sure it seems expensive, but combine
that with the cost reduction, you will
it will be reduced by at least one,
right? sometimes two, three, and the
equip is free. This is so efficient and
can really blow people out.
Next up is Cigardless Aid. I couldn't
find a regular version, but this is
called Cigardless Aid. Uh it's yeah, you
can cast equipments with flash and they
will attach. They will attach
automatically. What's amazing about this
is a lot of the uh protection ones like
indestructible, shroud, you can use them
as protection spells now. You can
surprise people. They try to remove your
stuff. You cast it and the next turn you
can smack with that equipment. Sweet.
And forge a new. This one is equipment
recursion. You get a one equipment back
and but what's even better is you can uh
well one equip at instant speed on your
turn and you can also pay zero for the
first equip. So what you can do is you
can for example smack with two creatures
and if they block one of them you can
move the equipment onto the other. Yeah,
you can do some tricks like that. And
also if they try to remove your stuff on
your turn, you can say if you have
lightning griefs, your entire board has
shroud. They're they're all protected.
So this is a lot of utility, not just
for the recursion. Yep. And that's the
cloud pile. This is the cloud pile. It's
a
the cloud deck. Next up, protection
spell. Once again, I am doing
protection, a lot of protection because
Cloud does so much, right? You keep him
alive, he will he will reward you
handsomely. So, first one is actually
kind of unconventional, but I'm looking
at it uh for the cycling ability. It's
three mana to cycle, but when you cycle
this card, put two plus one plus one
counters on up to one target creature or
vehicle against trample and
indestructible to the end of turn. So,
it's like kind of evasion, but more
importantly, indestructible protection
and you draw a card, right? That's super
important. Sure, it's three mana, a bit
expensive, but you get you draw a card
and you get to protect your creature
pretty well. And more importantly, it's
called Agna. Agnosaur Rex. It's a
creature, right? So, it's got two modes.
The other mode is also really powerful.
It's a five mana 88 trample,
right? That's just so efficient and it
fits it fits the deck's theme. It fits
the Tifa theme as well. So, just great
synergy all around. Next up, Borl's
Charm. It is not the strongest
protection spell. It's good because you
you want to protect your all your
permanence. Sometimes they board, they
kill your your equipments. That's the
hardest part to rebuild. Killing cloud
is okay cuz he's got haste, right? You
just cast him and you're you're already
smacking again. He pick up an equipment.
Yeah, you don't skip a beat. But if they
blow up your equipments, then you are
slowed down by a few turns. But here
with borrow borrow is protecting
everything. But what's the reason I
picked this over other protection spells
is the option to give double strike.
Yeah, cuz with what cloud is doing here,
double strike sometimes means just
killing a player and out of nowhere. So
it's a pretty versatile threat. You can
go on the defense or offense with it.
Shelter for protection spells. In decks
like these, I prefer protection from
color. This protects you from all spot
removals. Draws you a card, but in a
pinch, it can serve as almost a evasion
spell. Yeah, if your opponents are kind
of mono color or even just two colors,
sometimes they just have creatures of a
single color or they leave two blockers
up, they're both black, for example.
Yeah, this will really catch them off
guard.
Shelter protection for black. you can
swing, get your value, sometimes kill
someone. Yeah, again this I like cards
that can be used both offensively and
defensively and shelter is one of them.
Next up, SK uh snake skinville for the
versatility. Also, the pump because a
lot of our equipments give plus two and
just that plus one plus one counter can
make a huge difference. It can be the
difference between cloud triggering or
not. So, it's just a efficient simple
hex proof and plus one plus one. These
are our protection spells to make up a
total of let's see six. Yeah.
Next up, just one more removal
because this one is good just because it
is already one of the best boards. But
in our deck, sometimes we give Cloud
Protection from red, sometimes we give
it indestructible. And this is like an
evasion spell. You can wipe the board
and then uh attack someone for free
basically. So we are adding this to the
boardw pile. Again, we're not going too
heavy on board wipes and uh removals.
We're just depending on cloud to get the
job done. And we do need a little more
more draw aside from cloud. So again,
risk expertise. This is one of my
favorite draw spells in a big creatures
deck. In this deck, you will easily draw
six to eight and you get a spell for
free. So again, you're not you're
tapping out kind of paying a lot of mana
for this draw spell, but at the same
time, you're not. That's what's nice
about this card. You still get to cast
stuff.
And lastly, finisher
full throttle. This is the best extra
combat spell. You can with this you can
easily kill one sometimes two opponents
out of nowhere. Yeah, three combat
faces. Imagine getting cloud trigger on
all three of them. Yeah, you are you are
just way ahead as soon as you get this.
We don't want too many of these. Like if
you if it turns out that you you feel
like you're often waiting for this card,
then put in more. There are some other
decent ones, but this one is the best
one. And in a deck that is more
aggressive, we need finishes like this.
We can just be predictable and we can't
let the opponent count down. I've got
three turns. I've got two turns. I've
got one turn left. No, you need to
surprise them with some cards like this.
So, this is the deck for Cloud. And
yeah, we finished all four Final Fantasy
precon decks.
Thanks again for joining me. Please like
and subscribe and let me know if you
like this kind of content. Should I do
this for the next set of pre-cuts?
And that's all. I'll see you soon.